is that my name is Jim frigate I'm an
international as a pair of Time magazine
and I just goes to the sessions yes
achica houses I love is the CEO of two
potato fries oh okay we had a one-on-one
conversation as a problem-based
sustainable healthcare in aging
populations I think a couple of things
that were most interesting about that is
that there's definitely divide between
developing countries with population
young population is increasing and
developed countries like Japan easily
united states where the population is
actually a distressed about how do you
like fun those healthcare systems he had
several you know very interesting ideas
that countries with aging populations
could increase the immigration they
could increase their taxation think of
lower their entitlements but as these
are mostly developed democracies the
biggest problem is that old people's
other and young people don't and so
getting these changes entitlements to
shift to the younger smaller populations
is going to be particularly tough
because Dioner are they disenfranchised
from the political system period so
finding way to change that going forward
is his biggest challenge of me health
care industry worldwide and was one of
the most interesting drug detox